[Music]
the events which i am about to relate
took place between 9 and 10 years ago
sebastopol had fallen in the early
spring
the peace of paris had been concluded
since march
our commercial relations with the
russian empire were but recently renewed
and i returning home after my first
northward journey since the war
was well pleased with the prospect of
spending the month of december
under the hospitable and thoroughly
english roof of my excellent friend
jonathan jealth esquire of dumbleton
manor
clebra east anglia traveling in the
interests of the well-known firm
in which it is my lot to be a junior
partner i had been called upon to visit
not only the capitals of russia and
poland
but it also found it necessary to pass
some weeks among the trading ports of
the baltic
once it came that the year was already
far spent before i again set foot on
english soil
and that instead of shooting pheasants
with him as i had hoped in october
i came to be my friend's guest during
the morgenial christmas tide
my voyage over and a few days given up
to business
in liverpool and london i hasten down to
clebra with all the delight of a
schoolboy whose holidays are at hand
my way lay by the great east anglian
line as far as claiborous station
where i was to be met by one of the
dumbleton carriages and conveyed across
the remaining nine miles of country
it was a foggy afternoon singularly warm
for the 4th of december
and i had arranged to leave london by
the 415 express
the early darkness of winter had already
closed in
the lamps were lighted in the carriages
a clinging damp
dimmed the windows adhered to the door
handles and pervaded all the atmosphere
while the gas jets at the neighboring
bookstand diffused a luminous haze
that only served to make the gloom of
the terminus more visible
having arrived some seven minutes before
the starting of the train
and by the connivance of the guard taken
sole possession of an empty compartment
i lighted my traveling lamp made myself
particularly snug
and settled down to the undisturbed
enjoyment of a book in a cigar
great therefore was my disappointment
when at the last moment
a gentleman came hurrying along the
platform glanced into my carriage
opened the locked door with a private
key and stepped in
it struck me at the first glance that i
had seen him before
a tall spare man thin lipped light-eyed
with an ungraceful stoop in the
shoulders and scant gray hair
worn somewhat long upon the collar he
carried a light waterproof coat
an umbrella and a large brown japan deed
box
which last he placed under the seat this
done he felt carefully in his breast
pocket
as if to make certain of the safety of
his purse or pocketbook
laid his umbrella in the netting
overhead spread the waterproof across
his knees
and exchanged his hat for a traveling
cap of some scotch material
by this time the train was moving out of
the station and into the faint gray of
the wintry twilight beyond
i now recognized my companion i
recognized him from the moment when he
removed his hat
and uncovered the lofty furrowed and
somewhat narrow brow beneath
i had met him as i distinctly remembered
some three years before
at the very house for which in all
probability he was now bound
like myself his name was dwary house
he was a lawyer by profession and if i
was not greatly mistaken
was first cousin to the wife of my host
i knew also that he was a man
eminently well to do both as regarded
his professional
and private means the gelfs entertained
him with that sort of observant courtesy
which falls to the lot of the rich
relation
the children made much of him and the
old butler
albeit somewhat surly to the general
treated him with deference
i thought observing him by the vague
mixture of lamplight in twilight
that mrs jeff's cousin looked all the
worse for the three years
wear and tear which had gone over his
head since our last meeting
he was very pale and had a restless
light in his eye that i did not remember
to have observed before
the anxious lines too about his mouth
were deepened
and there was a cavernous hollow look
about his cheeks and temples
which seemed to speak of sickness or
sorrow
he had glanced at me as he came in but
without any gleam of recognition in his
face
now he glanced again as i fancied
somewhat doubtfully
when he did so for the third or fourth
time i ventured to address him
mr john dwary house i think that is my
name
he replied i had the pleasure of meeting
you at dumbleton
about three years ago mr dwerryhouse
bowed
i thought i knew your face he said but
your name i regret to say
langford william langford i have known
jonathan jalf since we were boys
together at merchant taylors
and i generally spend a few weeks at
dumbleton in the shooting season
i suppose we are bound for the same
destination
not if you are on your way to the manor
he replied
i am traveling upon business rather
troublesome business too
whilst you doubtless have only pleasure
in view
just so i'm in the habit of looking
forward to this visit
as to the brightest three weeks in all
the year
it is a pleasant house said mr
dwaryhouse
the pleasantest i know and jelf is
thoroughly hospitable
the best and kindest fellow in the world
they have invited me to spend christmas
week with them
pursued mr dwary house after a moment's
pause
and you are coming i cannot tell
it must depend on the issue of this
business which i have in hand
you have heard perhaps that we are about
to construct a branch line from
blackwater to stockbridge
i explained that i had been for some
months away from england
and had therefore heard nothing of the
contemplated improvement
mr duary house smiled complacently it
will be an improvement
he said a great improvement stockbridge
is a flourishing town
and needs but a more direct railway
communication with a metropolis to
become an important center of commerce
this branch was my own idea i brought
the project before the board
and have myself superintended the
execution of it up to the present time
you are an east anglian director i
presume
my interest in the company replied mr
duary house
is three-fold i am a director i am a
considerable shareholder
and is the head of the firm of dwary
house duary house and crake
i am the company's principal solicitor
loquacious self-important full of his
pet project
and apparently unable to talk on any
other subject
mr duary house then went on to tell of
the opposition he had encountered
and the obstacles he had overcome in the
cause of the stockbridge branch
i was entertained with a multitude of
local details and local grievances
the rapacity of one squire the
impracticability of another
the indignation of the rector whose
glebe was threatened
the culpable indifference of the
stockbridge townspeople
who could not be brought in to see that
their most vital interests hinged upon a
junction with the great east anglian
line
the spite of the local newspaper and the
unheard of difficulties attending the
common question
were each and all laid before me with a
circumstantiality that possessed the
deepest interest for my excellent fellow
traveler
but none whatever for myself from these
to my despair
he went on to more intricate matters to
the approximate expenses of construction
per mile
to the estimates sent in by different
contractors
to the probable traffic returns of the
new line to the provisional clauses of
the new act as enumerated in schedule d
of the company's last half-yearly report
and so on
and on and on till my head ached and my
attention flagged
and my eyes kept closing in spite of
every effort that i made to keep them
open
at length i was roused by these words
seventy-five thousand pounds cash
seventy down thousand pounds cashed down
i repeated
in the liveliest tone i could assume
that is a heavy sum
a heavy sum to carry here replied mr
dwary house
pointing significantly to his breast
pocket but a mere fraction of what we
shall ultimately have to pay
you do not mean to say that you have 75
000 pounds at this moment upon your
person
i exclaimed my good sir have i not been
telling you so for the last half hour
said mr duary house testily that money
has to be paid over at half past eight
o'clock this evening
at the office of sir thomas's solicitors
on completion of the deed of sale
but how will you get across by night
from blackwater to stockbridge with 75
thousand pounds in your pocket to
stockbridge
echoed the lawyer i find i've made
myself very imperfectly understood
i thought i had explained how this sum
only carries us as far as mallingford
the first stage as it were of our
journey and how our route from
blackwater to mallingford lies entirely
through sir thomas liddell's property
i beg your pardon i stammered i fear my
thoughts were wandering
so you only go as far as mallingford
tonight precisely
i shall get a conveyance from the
blackwater arms and you
oh jelf sends a trap to meet me at
clebra
can i be the bearer of any message from
you you may say if you please mr
langford that i wished i could have been
your companion all the way
and that i will come over if possible
before christmas
nothing more mr duary house smiled
grimly
well he said you may tell my cousin that
she need not burn the hall down in my
honor this time
and that i shall be obliged if she will
order the blue rim chimney to be swept
before i arrive
that sounds tragic had you a
conflagration on the occasion of your
last visit to dumbleton
something like it there had been no fire
lighted in my bedroom since the spring
the flu was foul and the rooks had built
in it
so when i went up to dress for dinner i
found the room full of smoke and the
chimney on fire
are we all ready at blackwater the train
had gradually come to a pause while mr
dwaryhouse was speaking
and on putting my head out of the window
i could see the station some few hundred
yards ahead
there was another train before us
blocking the way and the guard was
making use of the delay to collect the
blackwater tickets
i had scarcely ascertained our position
when the ruddy-faced official appeared
at our carriage door
ticket sir said he i am for clebra
i replied holding out the tiny pink card
he took it
glanced at it by the light of his little
lantern gave it back
looked as i fancied somewhat sharply at
my fellow traveler and disappeared
he did not ask for yours i said with
some surprise
they never do replied mr dwary house
they all know me
and of course i travel free blackwater
blackwater cried the porter running
along the platform beside us as we
glided into the station
mr dwarihaus pulled out his deed box put
his traveling cap in his pocket
resumed his hat took down his umbrella
and prepared to be gone
many thanks mr langford for your society
he said with old-fashioned courtesy
i wish you a good evening good evening i
replied putting out my hand
but he either did not see it or did not
choose to see it
and slightly lifting his hat stepped out
upon the platform
having done this he moved slowly away
and mingled with a departing crowd
leaning forward to watch him out of
sight i trod upon something which proved
to be a cigar case
it had fallen no doubt from the pocket
of his waterproof coat
and was made of dark morocco leather
with a silver monogram upon the side
i sprang out of the carriage just as the
guard came up to lock me in
is there one minute to spare i asked
eagerly the gentleman who traveled down
with me from town has dropped his cigar
case he's not yet out of the station
[Music]
just a minute and a half sir replied the
guard you must be quick
i dashed along the platform as fast as
my feet would carry me
it was a large station and mr dwary
house had by this time got more than
halfway to the farther end
i however saw him distinctly moving
slowly with the stream
then as i drew nearer i saw that he had
met some friend
that they were talking as they walked
that they presently fell back somewhat
from the crowd
and stood aside in earnest conversation
i made straight for the spot where they
were waiting
there was a vivid gas jet just above
their heads and the light fell
full upon their faces i saw both
distinctly the face of mr dwary house
and the face of his companion
running breathless eager as i was
getting in the way of porters and
passengers
and fearful every instant lest i should
see the train going on without me
i yet observed that the newcomer was
considerably younger and shorter than
the director
that he was sandy-haired mustachioed
small featured
and dressed in a close-cut suit of
scotch tweed
i was now within a few yards of them i
ran against a stout gentleman
i was nearly knocked down by a luggage
truck i stumbled over a carpet bag
i gained the spot just as the driver's
whistle warned me to return
to my utter stupefaction they were no
longer there
i had seen them but two seconds before
and they were gone
i stood still i looked to right and left
i saw no sign of them in any direction
it was as if the platform had gaped and
swallowed them
there were two gentlemen standing here a
moment ago i said to a porter at my
elbow
which way can they have gone i saw no
gentleman sir
replied the man the whistle shrilled out
again
the guard far up the platform held up
his arm and shouted to me to come on
if you're going on by this train sir
said the porter you must run for it
i did run for it just gained the
carriage as the train began to move
was shoved in by the guard and left
breathless and bewildered
with mr dwary house's cigar case still
in my hand
it was the strangest disappearance in
the world it was like a transformation
trick in a pantomime
they were there one moment palpably
there talking with the gas
light full upon their faces and the next
moment they were gone
there was no door near no window no
staircase
it was a mere slip of barren platform
tapestry with big advertisements
could anything be more mysterious
it was not worth thinking about and yet
for my life i could not help pondering
upon it
pondering wondering conjecturing turning
it over and over in my mind
and beating my brains for a solution of
the enigma
i thought of it all the way from
blackwater to clebura
i thought of it all the way from
cleburne to dumbleton as i rattled along
the smooth highway in a trimmed dog cart
drawn by a splendid black mare
and driven by the silentist and
dapperist of east anglian grooms
we did the nine miles in something less
than an hour and pulled up before the
lodge gates just as the church clock was
striking half past
seven a couple of minutes more and the
warm glow of the lighted hall was
flooding out upon the gravel
a hearty grasp was on my hand and a
clear jovial voice was bidding me
welcome to dumbleton
and now my dear fellow said my host when
the first greeting was over
you have no time to spare we dine at
eight and there are people coming to
meet you
so you must just get the dressing
business over as quickly as may be
by the way you will meet some
acquaintances the bid officer coming
the prendergast prendergast of the
skirmishers is staying in the house
adieu mrs jelf will be expecting you in
the drawing room
i was ushered to my room not the blue
room of which mr dwary house had made
disagreeable experience
but a pretty little bachelor's chamber
hung with a delicate chintz
and made cheerful by a blazing fire i
unlocked my portmanteau
i tried to be expeditious but the memory
of my railway adventure haunted me
i could not get free of it i could not
shake it off
it impeded me it worried me it tripped
me up
it caused me to mislay my studs to
mistie my cravat
to wrench the buttons off my gloves
worst of all it made me so late that the
party had all assembled before i reached
the drawing room
i had scarcely paid my respects to mrs
jelf when dinner was announced and we
paired off
some eight or ten couples strong into
the dining room
i'm not going to describe either the
guests or the dinner
all provincial parties bear the
strictest family resemblance
and i am not aware that an east anglian
banquet offers any exception to the rule
there was the usual country baronet and
his wife there were the usual country
parsons and their wives
there was the sempaternal turkey and
haunch of venison
vanitas vanitatum there is nothing new
under the sun
i was placed about midway down the table
i had taken one rector's wife down to
dinner and i had another at my left hand
they talked across me and their talk was
about babies
it was dreadfully dull at length there
came a pause
the entrees had just been removed and
the turkey had come upon the scene
the conversation had all along been of
the languidest but at this moment it
happened to have stagnated altogether
jelf was carving the turkey mrs jelf
looked as if she was trying to think of
something to say
everybody else was silent moved by an
unlucky impulse i thought i would relate
my adventure
by the way jelf i began i came down part
of the way today with a friend of yours
indeed said the master of the feast
slicing scientifically into the breast
of the turkey
with whom pray with one who bade me tell
you that he should if possible pay you a
visit before christmas
i cannot think who that could be said my
friend smiling
it must be major thorpe suggested mrs
jelf
i shook my head it was not major thorpe
i replied
it was a near relation of your own mrs
jelf
then i am more puzzled than ever replied
my hostess
pray tell me who it was it was no less a
person than your cousin
mr john dwarihaus jonathan jelf laid
down his knife and fork
mrs jelf looked at me in a strange
startled way
and said never a word and he desired me
to tell you my dear madam
that you need not take the trouble to
burn the hall down in his honor this
time
but only to have the chimney of the blue
room swept before his arrival
before i had reached the end of my
sentence i became aware of something
ominous in the faces of the guests
i felt i had said something which i had
better have left unsaid
and that for some unexplained reason my
words had evoked a general consternation
i sat confounded not daring to utter
another syllable
and for at least two whole minutes there
was dead silence around the table
then captain prendergast came to the
rescue
you have been abroad for some months
have you not mr langford
he said with the desperation of one who
flings himself into the breach
i heard you had been to russia surely
you have something to tell us of the
state and temper of the country after
the war
i was heartily grateful to the gallant
skirmisher for this diversion in my
favor
i answered him my fear somewhat lamely
but he kept the conversation up
and presently one or two others joined
in and so the difficulty whatever it
might have been
was bridged over bridged over but not
repaired
a something an awkwardness a visible
constraint
remained the guests hitherto had been
simply dull but now they were evidently
uncomfortable
and embarrassed the dessert had scarcely
been placed
upon the table when the ladies left the
room i seized the opportunity to select
a vacant chair next to captain
prendergast
in heaven's name i whispered what was
the matter just now
what had i said you mentioned the name
of john dwarihaus
what of that i had seen him not two
hours before
it is a most astounding circumstance
that you should have seen him
said captain prendergast are you sure it
was he
as sure as of my own identity we were
talking all the way between london and
blackwater
but why does that surprise you because
replied captain prendergast dropping his
voice to the lowest whisper
because john wary house absconded three
months ago with 75 000 pounds of the
company's money
and has never been heard of since
john dwarihaus had absconded three
months ago
and i had seen him only a few hours back
john's wary house had embezzled 75 000
pounds of the company's money
yet told me that he carried that sum
upon his person
were ever facts so strangely incongruous
so difficult to reconcile
how should he have ventured again into
the light of day how dare to show
himself along the line
above all what had he been doing
throughout those mysterious three months
of disappearance
perplexing questions these questions
which it once suggested themselves to
the minds of all concerned
but which admitted of no easy solution i
could find no reply to them
captain prendergast had not even a
suggestion to offer
jonathan jalf who sees the first
opportunity of drawing me aside and
learning all that i had to tell
was more amazed and bewildered than
either of us
he came to my room that night when all
the guests were gone
and we talked the thing over from every
point of view without it must be
confessed
arriving at any kind of conclusion
i do not ask you he said whether you
can't have mistaken your man
that is impossible as impossible is that
i should mistake some stranger for
yourself
it is not a question of looks or voice
but of facts
that he should have alluded to the fire
in the blue room as proof enough
of john dwarihau's identity how did he
look
older i thought considerably older paler
and more anxious he's had enough to make
him look anxious
anyhow said my friend gloomily be he
innocent or guilty
i am inclined to believe that he is
innocent i replied
he showed no embarrassment when i
addressed him and no uneasiness when the
guard came round
his conversation was open to a fault i
might almost say that he talked too
freely
of the business which he had in hand
that again is strange for i know no one
more reticent on such subjects
he actually told you that he had the 75
000 pounds in his pocket
he did huh my wife has an idea about it
and she may be right
what idea well she fancies
women are so clever you know at putting
themselves inside people's motives
she fancies that he was tempted that he
did actually take the money
and that he has been concealing himself
these three months in some wild part of
the country
struggling possibly with his conscience
all the time and daring neither to
abscond with his booty
nor to come back and restore it but now
that he has come back that is the point
she conceives that he has probably
thrown himself upon the company's mercy
made restitution of the money and being
forgiven is permitted to carry the
business through as if nothing whatever
had happened
the last i replied is an impossible case
mrs gelf thinks like a generous and
delicate-minded woman
but not in the least like a board of
railway directors
they would never carry forgiveness so
far
i fear not and yet it is the only
conjecture that bears a semblance of
likelihood
however we can run over to clabora
tomorrow and see if anything is to be
learned
by the way prendergast tells me you
picked up his cigar case
i did so and here it is
jelf took the cigar case examined it by
the light of the lamp
and said at once that it was beyond
doubt mr dwary house's property
and that he remembered to have seen him
use it
here too is his monogram on the side he
added
a big j transfixing a capital d he used
to carry the same on his note paper
it offers at all events a proof that i
was not dreaming
i but it is time you were asleep and
dreaming now i am ashamed to have kept
you up so long
good night good night and remember that
i am more than ready to go with you to
claybora or blackwater or london or
anywhere
if i can be of the least service thanks
i know you mean it old friend
and it may be that i shall put you to
the test once more
good night so we parted for that night
and met again in the breakfast room at
half past eight next morning
it was a hurried silent uncomfortable
meal
none of us had slept well and all were
thinking of the same subject
mrs jelf had evidently been crying jelf
was impatient to be off
and both captain prendergast and myself
felt ourselves to be in the painful
position of outsiders who were
involuntarily brought into a domestic
trouble
within 20 minutes after we had left the
breakfast table the dog cart was brought
round
and my friend and i were on the road to
clebra
tell you what it is langford he said as
we sped along between the wintry hedges
i do not much fancy to bring up duary
house's name at clebra
all the officials know that he is my
wife's relation and the subject just now
is hardly a pleasant one if you don't
much mind we will take the 1110 to
blackwater
it's an important station and we shall
stand a far better chance of picking up
information there
than at clebra so we took the 1110
which happened to be an express and
arriving at blackwater about a quarter
before 12
proceeded at once to prosecute our
inquiry
we began by asking for the station
master a big blunt business-like person
who at once averred that he knew mr john
dwary house perfectly well
and that there was no director on the
line whom he had seen and spoken to so
frequently
he used to be down here two or three
times a week about three months ago
said he when the new line was first set
afoot
but since then you know gentlemen he
paused significantly
jelf flushed scarlet yes yes he said
hurriedly
we know all about that the point now to
be ascertained is whether anything has
been seen or heard of him lately
not to my knowledge replied the station
master
he is not known to have been down the
line any time yesterday for instance
the station master shook his head the
east anglian sir
said he is about the last place where he
would dare to show himself
why there isn't a station master there
isn't a guard there isn't a porter
who doesn't know mr tuary house by sight
as well as he knows his own face in the
looking glass
or who wouldn't telegraph for the police
as soon as he had set eyes on him at any
point along the line
bless you sir there's been a standing
order out against him
ever since the 25th of september last
and yet pursued my friend a gentleman
who traveled down yesterday
from london to clebura by the afternoon
express
testifies that he saw mr dwary house in
the train
and that mr dwaryhouse alighted at
blackwater station
quite impossible sir replied the station
master promptly
why impossible because there is no
station along the line where he is so
well known
or where he would run so great a risk it
would just be running his head into the
lion's mouth
he would have been mad to come nigh
blackwater station and if he had come
he would have been arrested before he
left the platform
can you tell me who took the blackwater
tickets of that train
i can sir it was the guard benjamin
summers
and where can i find him you can find
him sir by staying here
if you please till 1 o'clock he will be
coming through with the up express from
crampton
which stays at blackwater for 10 minutes
we waited for the up express beguiling
the time as best we could by strolling
along the blackwater road
till we came almost to the outskirts of
the town from which the station was
distant nearly a couple of miles
by one o'clock we were back again upon
the platform and waiting for the train
it came punctually and i at once
recognized the ruddy-faced guard who had
gone down with my train the evening
before
the gentleman want to ask you something
about mr dwerryhouse summers
said the station master by way of
introduction
the guard flashed a keen glance from my
face to jelves and back again to mine
mr john dwarihaus the late director said
he interrogatively
the same replied my friend should you
know him if you saw him
anywhere sir do you know if he was in
the 415 express
yesterday afternoon he was not sir
how can you answer so positively because
i looked into every carriage
and saw every face in that train and i
could take my oath that mr dwary house
was not in it
this gentleman was he added turning
sharply upon me
i don't know that i ever saw him before
in my life but i remember his face
perfectly
you nearly missed taking your seat in
time at this station sir and you got out
at clebra
quite true guard i replied but do you
not also remember the face of the
gentleman who traveled down in the same
carriage with me
as far as here it was my impression sir
that you traveled down alone
said summers with a look of some
surprise
by no means i had a fellow traveler as
far as blackwater
and it was in trying to restore him the
cigar case which he had dropped in the
carriage that i so nearly let you go on
without me
i remember you're saying something about
a cigar case certainly
replied the guard but you asked for my
ticket just before we entered the
station
i did sir then you must have seen him he
sat in the corner next to the very door
to which you came
no indeed i saw no one i looked at jelf
i began to think the guard was in the
ex-director's confidence and paid for
his silence
if i had seen another traveler i should
have asked for his ticket
added summers did you see me ask for his
ticket sir
i observed that you did not ask for it
but he explained that by saying
i hesitated i feared i might be telling
too much and so broke off abruptly
the guard and the station master
exchanged glances
the former looked impatiently at his
watch i am obliged to go on in four
minutes more sir
he said one last question then
interposed jelf with a sort of
desperation
if this gentleman's fellow traveler had
been mr john twarryhouse
and he had been sitting in the corner
next to the door by which you took the
tickets
could you have failed to see and
recognize him
no sir it would have been quite
impossible
and you were certain you did not see him
as i said before sir
i could take my oath i did not see him
and if it wasn't that i don't like to
contradict a gentleman
i would say i could also take my oath
that this gentleman was quite alone in
the carriage the whole way from london
to clebura
why sir he added dropping his voice so
as to be inaudible to the station master
who had been called away to speak to
some person close by
you expressly asked me to give you a
compartment to yourself
and i did so i locked you in and you
were so good as to give me something for
myself
yes but mr dwary house had a key of his
own
i never saw him sir i saw no one in that
compartment but yourself
beg pardon sir my time's up and with
this
the ruddy guard touched his cap and was
gone
in another minute the heavy panting of
the engine began afresh
and the train glided slowly out of the
station
we looked at each other for some moments
in silence
i was the first to speak mr benjamin
summers knows more than he chooses to
tell
i said do you think so
it must be he could not have come to the
door without seeing him
it's impossible there is one thing not
impossible my dear fellow
what is that that you may have fallen
asleep
and dreamt the whole thing could i dream
of a branch line that i had never heard
of
could i dream of 101 business details
that had no kind of interest for me
could i dream of the 75 000 pounds
perhaps you might have seen or heard
some vague account of the affair while
you were abroad
it might have made no impression upon
you at the time and might have come back
to you in your dreams
recalled perhaps by the mere names of
the stations on the line
what about the fire in the chimney of
the blue room should i have heard of
that during my journey
well no i admit there is a difficulty
about that point
and what about the cigar case aye by
jove there is the cigar case
that is a stubborn fact well it's a
mysterious affair
and it will need a better detective than
myself i fancy to clear it up
i suppose we may as well go home
a week had not gone by when i received a
letter from the secretary
of the east anglian railway company
requesting the favor of my attendance at
a special board meeting
not then many days distant no reasons
were alleged and no apologies offered
for this demand upon my time but they
had heard it was clear of my inquiries
about the missing director
and had a mind to put me through some
sort of official examination upon the
subject
being still a guest at dumbleton hall i
had to go up to london for the purpose
and jonathan jelf accompanied me i found
the direction of the great east anglian
line represented by a party of some 12
or 14 gentlemen
seated in solemn conclave round a huge
green bays table
in a gloomy boardroom adjoining the
london terminus
being courteously received by the
chairman who at once began by saying
that certain statements of mine
respecting mr john twarry house had come
to the knowledge of the direction
and that they in consequence desire to
confer with me on those points
we were placed at the table and the
inquiry proceeded in due form
i was first asked if i knew mr john
dwarihaus
how long i had been acquainted with him
and whether i could identify him at
sight
i was then asked when i had seen him
last to which i replied
on the fourth of this present month
december 1856
then came the inquiry of where i had
seen him on that fourth day of december
to which i replied that i met him in a
first class compartment
of the 415 down express that he got in
just as the train was leaving the london
terminus
and that he alighted at blackwater
station
the chairman then inquired whether i had
held any communication with my fellow
traveler
whereupon i related as nearly as i could
remember it
the whole bulk and substance of mr
john's wary house's diffuse information
respecting the new branch line
to all this the board listened with
profound attention
while the chairman presided and the
secretary took notes
i then produced the cigar case it was
passed from hand to hand
and recognized by all there was not a
man present who did not remember
that plain cigar case with its silver
monogram or to whom it seemed anything
less than entirely corroborative of my
evidence
when at length i had told all that i had
to tell the chairman whispered something
to the secretary
the secretary touched a silver hand bell
and the guard benjamin summers
was ushered into the room he was then
examined as carefully as myself
he declared that he knew mr john
twarryhouse perfectly well
that he could not be mistaken in him
that he remembered going down with the
415 express on the afternoon in question
that he remembered me and that there
being one or two empty first class
compartments on that a special afternoon
he had in compliance with my request
placed me in a carriage by myself
he was positive that i remained alone in
that compartment
all the way from london to clebra he was
ready to take his oath that mr dwary
house was neither in that carriage with
me
nor in any compartment of that train he
remembered distinctly to have examined
my ticket at blackwater
was certain that there was no one else
at that time in the carriage
could not have failed to observe a
second person if there had been one
had that second person been mr john
dwary house should have quietly double
locked the door of the carriage
and have at once given information to
the blackwater station master
so clear so decisive so ready was
summers with his testimony
that the board looked fairly puzzled you
hear this person's statement mr langford
said the chairman it contradicts yours
in every particular
what have you to say in reply i can only
repeat what i said before
i am quite as positive of the truth of
my own assertions as mr summers can be
of the truth of his
you say that mr dwary house alighted at
blackwater and that he was in possession
of a private key
are you sure that he had not allighted
by means of that key before the guard
came round for the tickets
i am quite positive that he did not
leave the carriage till the train had
fairly entered the station
and the other blackwater passengers
alighted i even saw that he was met
there by a friend
indeed did you see that person
distinctly
quite distinctly can you describe his
appearance
i think so he was short and very slight
sandy-haired
with a bushy mustache and beard and he
wore a closely fitting suit of gray
tweed
his age i should take to be about 38 or
40.
did mr dwary house leave the station in
this person's company
i cannot tell i saw them walking
together in the platform
and then i saw them standing aside under
a gas jet talking earnestly
after that i lost sight of them quite
suddenly and just then my train went on
and i with it the chairman and secretary
conferred together in an undertone
the directors whispered to each other
one or two looked suspiciously at the
guard
i could see that my evidence remained
unshaken and that like myself they
suspected some complicity between the
guard and the defaulter
how far did you conduct that 415 express
on the day in question summers
asked the chairman all through sir
replied the guard
from london to crampton how was it that
you were not relieved at clebra
i thought there was always a change of
guards at clebra
there used to be sir till the new
regulations came in force
last mid-summer since when the guards in
charge of express trains go the whole
way through
the chairman turned to the secretary i
think it would be as well
he said if we had the day book to refer
to upon this point
again the secretary touched the silver
handbell and desired the porter in
attendance to summon mr rakes
from a word or two dropped by another of
the directors i gathered that mr rakes
was one of the undersecretaries
he came a small slight sandy-haired
keen-eyed man
with an eager nervous manner and a
forest of light beard and mustache
he just showed himself at the door of
the boardroom and being requested to
bring a certain day book from a certain
shelf in a certain room
bowed and vanished he was there
such a moment and the surprise of seeing
him was so great and sudden
that it was not till the door had closed
upon him that i found voice to speak
he was no sooner gone however than i
sprang to my feet
that person i said is the same who met
mr dwaryhouse upon the platform at
blackwater
there was a general movement of surprise
the chairman looked grave
and somewhat agitated take care mr
langford
he said take care what you say i am as
positive of his identity as of my own
do you consider the consequences of your
words do you consider that you are
bringing a charge of the gravest
character
against one of the company's servants i
am willing to be put upon my oath if
necessary
the man who came to that door a minute
since is the same whom i saw
talking with mr dwary house on the
blackwater platform
were he 20 times the company's servant i
could say neither more nor less
the chairman turned again to the guard
did you see mr rakes in the train
or on the platform he asked summers
shook his head
i am confident mr ranks was not in the
train he said and i certainly did not
see him on the platform
the chairman turned next to the
secretary mr rakes is in your office mr
hunter
he said can you remember if he was
absent on the fourth instant
i do not think he was replied the
secretary but i am not prepared to speak
positively
i have been away most afternoons myself
lately and mr rakes might easily have
absented himself
if he had been disposed at this moment
the undersecretary returned with a day
book under his arm
be pleased to refer mr rakes said the
chairman to the entries of the fourth
instant
and see what benjamin summer's duties
were on that day
mr rakes threw open the cumbress volume
and ran a practiced eye and finger
down some three or four successive
columns of entries
stopping suddenly at the foot of a page
he then read aloud that benjamin summers
had on that day
conducted the 415 express from london to
crampton
the chairman leaned forward in his seat
looked the undersecretary full in the
face
and said quite sharply and suddenly
where were you
mr rakes on the same afternoon i sir
you mr rakes where were you on the
afternoon and evening of the fourth of
the present month
here sir in mr hunter's office where
else should i be
there was a dash of trepidation in the
undersecretary's voice as he said this
but his look of surprise was natural
enough
we have some reason for believing mr
rakes that you were absent that
afternoon without leave
was this the case certainly not sir
i have not had a day's holiday since
september mr hunter will bear me out in
this
mr hunter repeated what he had
previously said on the subject
but added that the clerks in the
adjoining office would be certain to
know
whereupon the senior cleric a grave
middle-aged person
in green glasses was summoned and
interrogated
his testimony cleared the under
secretary at once
he declared that mr rakes had in no
instance to his knowledge
been absent during office hours since
his return from his annual holiday in
september
i was confounded the chairman turned to
me with a smile
in which a shade of covert annoyance was
scarcely apparent
you hear mr langford he said i hear sir
but my conviction remains unshaken
i fear mr lankford that your convictions
are very insufficiently based
replied the chairman with a doubtful
cough i fear that you dream dreams and
mistake them for actual occurrences
it is a dangerous habit of mind and
might lead to dangerous results
mr rakesh here would have found himself
in an unpleasant position
had he not proved so satisfactory in
alibi
i was about to reply but he gave me no
time
i think gentlemen he went on to say
addressing the board
that we should be wasting time to push
this inquiry further
mr lankford's evidence would seem to be
of an equal value throughout
the testimony of benjamin summers
disproves his first statement
and the testimony of the last witness
disproves his second
i think we may conclude that mr lankford
fell asleep in the train
on the occasion of his journey to
clebura and dreamt an
unusually vivid and circumstantial dream
of which however
we have now heard quite enough there are
few things more annoying than to find
one's positive convictions
met with incredulity i could not help
feeling impatience at the turn that
affairs had taken
i was not proof against the civil
sarcasm of the chairman's manor
most intolerable of all however was the
quiet smile
lurking about the corners of benjamin
summer's mouth
and the half-triumphant tough malicious
gleam in the eyes of the undersecretary
the man was evidently puzzled and
somewhat alarmed
his look seemed furtively to interrogate
me
who was i what did i want why had i come
here to do him an ill turn with his
employers
what was it to me whether or not he was
absent without leave
seeing all this and perhaps more
irritated by it than the thing deserved
i begged leave to detain the attention
of the board for a moment longer
jelf plucked me impatiently by the
sleeve
better let the thing drop he whispered
the chairman's right enough
you dreamt it and the less said now the
better
i was not to be silenced however in this
fashion
i had yet something to say and i would
say it
it was to this effect that dreams were
not usually productive of tangible
results
and then i requested to know in what way
the chairman conceived i had evolved
from my dream so substantial and well
made a delusion
as the cigar case which i had had the
honor to place before him
at the commencement of our interview the
cigar case i admit mr langford the
chairman replied
is a very strong point in your evidence
it is your only strong point however
and there is just a possibility that we
may all be misled by a mere
accidental resemblance will you permit
me to see the case again
it is unlikely i said as i handed it to
him that any others should bear
precisely this monogram
and yet be in all other particulars
exactly similar
the chairman examined it for a moment in
silence and then passed it to mr hunter
mr hunter turned it over and over and
shook his head
this is no mere resemblance he said it
is john dwarihau's cigar case to a
certainty
i remember it perfectly i have seen it a
hundred times
i believe i may say the same added the
chairman
yet how account for the way in which mr
lankford asserts that it came into his
possession
i can only repeat i replied that i found
it on the floor of the carriage after mr
dwary house had alighted
it was in leaning out to look after him
that i trod upon it and it was in
running after him for the purpose of
restoring it that i saw
or believed i saw mr rakes standing
aside with him in earnest conversation
again i felt jonathan jealth plucking at
my sleeve
look at rakes he whispered look at rakes
i turned to where the under secretary
had been standing a moment before
and saw him white as death with lips
trembling and livid
stealing towards the door to conceive a
sudden strange and indefinite suspicion
to fling myself in his way to take him
by the shoulders as if he were a child
and turn his craven face per force
towards the board
were with me the work of an instant look
at him
i exclaimed look at his face i ask no
better witness to the truth of my words
the chairman's brow darkened mr rakes
he said sternly if you know anything you
had better speak
vainly trying to wrench himself from my
grasp the undersecretary stammered out
an incoherent denial
let me go he said i know nothing you
have no right to detain me
let me go did you or did you not
meet mr john dwary house at blackwater
station the charge brought against you
is either true or false
if true you will do well to throw
yourself upon the mercy of the board
and make full confession of all that you
know
the undersecretary rung his hands in an
agony of helpless terror
i was away he cried i was 200 miles away
at the time
i know nothing about it i have nothing
to confess
i am innocent i call god to witness i am
innocent
200 miles away echoed the chairman what
do you mean
i was in devonshire i had three weeks
leave of absence
i appealed to mr hunter mr hunter knows
i had three weeks leave of absence
i was in devonshire all the time i can
prove i was in devonshire
seeing him so abject so incoherent so
wild with apprehension
the directors began to whisper gravely
among themselves
while one got quietly up and called the
porter to guard the door
what is your being in devonshire to do
with the matter said the chairman
when were you in debbincher mr rakes
took his leave in september
said the secretary about the time when
mr dwarihaus disappeared
i never even heard that he had
disappeared till i came back
that must remain to be proved said the
chairman i shall at once put this matter
in the hands of the police
in the meanwhile mr rakes being myself a
magistrate
and used to deal with these cases i
advise you to offer no resistance
but to confess while confession may yet
do you service
as for your accomplice the frightened
wretch fell upon his knees
i had no accomplice he cried only have
mercy upon me only spare my life and i
will confess all
i didn't mean to harm him i didn't mean
to hurt a hair of his head
only have mercy upon me and let me go
the chairman rose in his place pale and
agitated
good heavens he exclaimed what horrible
mystery is this
what does it mean as sure as there is a
god in heaven
said jonathan jelf it means that murder
has been done
no no no shrieked rakes still upon his
knees and cowering like a beaten hound
not murder no jury that ever sat could
bring it in murder
i thought i had only stunned him i never
meant to do more than stun him
manslaughter manslaughter not murder
overcome by the horror of this
unexpected revelation
the chairman covered his face with his
hand and for a moment or two remained
silent
miserable man he said at length you have
betrayed yourself
you made me confess you urged me to
throw myself upon the mercy of the board
you have confessed to a crime which no
one suspected you of having committed
replied the chairman and which this
board has no power either to punish or
forgive
all that i can do for you is to advise
you to submit to the law to plead guilty
and to conceal nothing when did you do
this deed
the guilty man rose to his feet and
leaned heavily against the table
his answer came reluctantly like the
speech of one dreaming
on the 22nd of september
on the 22nd of september i looked in
jonathan jelf's face
and he and mine i felt my own paling
with a strange sense of wonder and dread
i saw him blanch suddenly
even to the lips merciful heaven he
whispered
what was it then that you saw in the
train
what was it that i saw in the train that
question remains unanswered to this day
i have never been able to reply to it i
only know that it bore the living
likeness of the murdered man
whose body had then been lying some ten
weeks under a rough pile of branches and
brambles and rotting leaves
at the bottom of a deserted chalk pit
about halfway between blackwater and
mallingford
i know that it spoke and moved and
looked as that man spoke and moved and
looked in life
that i heard or seemed to hear things
related which i could never otherwise
have learned
that i was guided as it were by that
vision on the platform
to the identification of the murderer
and that a passive instrument myself
i was destined by means of these
mysterious teachings
to bring about the ends of justice for
these things
i have never been able to account as for
that matter of the cigar case
it proved on inquiry that the carriage
in which i traveled down that afternoon
to clebura
had not been in use for several weeks
and was in point of fact the same in
which poor john dwarihaus had performed
his last journey
the case had doubtless been dropped by
him and it lain unnoticed till i found
it
upon the details of the murder i have no
need to dwell
those who desire more ample particulars
may find them
and the written confession of augustus
rakes in the files of the times for 1856
enough that the under secretary knowing
the history of the new line
and following the negotiations step by
step through all its stages
determined to waylay mr duary house rob
him of the 75 000 pounds
and escape to america with his booty
in order to affect these ends he
obtained leave of absence a few days
before the time appointed for the
payment of the money
secured his passage across the atlantic
and a steamer
advertised to start on the 23rd provided
himself with a heavily loaded life
preserver
and went down to blackwater to await the
arrival of his victim
howie met him on the platform with a
pretended message from the board
how he offered to conduct him by a
shortcut across the fields to
mallingford
how having brought him to a lonely place
he struck him down with a life preserver
and so killed him and how finding what
he had done
he dragged the body to the verge of an
out of the way chalk pit
and there flung it in and piled it over
with branches and brambles
are facts still fresh in the memories of
those who
like the connoisseurs and de quincy's
famous essay regard murder as a fine art
strangely enough the murderer having
done his work
was afraid to leave the country he
declared that he had not intended to
take the director's life
but only to stun and rob him and that
finding the blow had killed
he dared not fly for fear of drawing
down suspicion upon his own head
as a mere robber he would have been safe
in the states
but as a murderer he would inevitably
have been pursued and given up to
justice
so he forfeited his passage returned to
the office as usual
at the end of his leave and locked up
his ill-gotten thousands till a more
convenient opportunity
in the meanwhile he had the satisfaction
of finding that mr dwary house was
universally believed to have absconded
with the money
no one knew how or whether whether he
meant murder or not however
mr augustus rakes paid the full penalty
of his crime
and was hanged at the old bailly in the
second week in january 1857
those who desire to make his further
acquaintance may see him any day
admirably done in wax in the chamber of
horrors at madame tussaud's exhibition
in baker street
he is there to be found in the midst of
a select society of ladies and gentlemen
of atrocious memory
dressed in the close-cut tweed suit
which he wore on the evening of the
murder
and holding in his hand the identical
life preserver with which he committed
it
you